what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are finally wrapping up
ultimatum we're finally grabbing up the
ultimatum story and and I'm pretty
excited about this it's it's a five
issue story and it's one of the coolest
things ultimatums pretty damn solid
again I like it I know it like people
kind of it really split the community
because a lot of people were just kind
of like man this is crazy and maybe the
reason why so is it cuz I know some of
you guys are just kind like this story's
amazing and maybe it's one of those
things where you kind of have to have
read the ultimate universe in its
entirety up to this point in order to
really understand her at the very least
ultimate x-men in order to really
understand how it kind of went off the
rails but again I don't really think it
did I think it was a story that was just
really interesting and really really fun
but still so we're at this point now
really at the end were like everybody
confronts magneto right like that was a
whole idea it was magneto versus the
Marvel Universe the idea that magneto
had taken the thor of hammer
he uses his control over magnetism and
reversed the Earth's magnetic poles and
just set in motion like this catastrophe
that basically wiped out like millions
and millions of people it was it was
humans it was mutants it was it was
heroes villains a whole nine yards I
mean it was everything like literally
just like millions and millions of
people died and so what the x-men
showing up and responding this is one of
the funny things this is really more of
a tribute to fatal attractions and
that's one of the things to bear in mind
here when it comes to the Ultimate
Universe because of the fact that you're
talking about a new line basically of
Marvel Comics that have been launched
off the back of what had basically been
like 50 years of comic book storytelling
you'd be hard-pressed to tell a story
that hadn't been told before and so it
was basically going through and just
kind of like reworking existing ideas
and then modifying them in a way that
made sense when it came to fatal
attractions it was this this concept
that really magneto had created a kind
of Citadel on you know out out in space
and that mutants could take up residence
on and leave the planet Earth well the
problem with this was that in the fatal
attraction story humanity thought that
magneto was essentially mobilizing an
army and so the idea was that they want
to go kind of launch the first strike at
least or if I remember correctly maybe
was Fabian Cortez who did it ah but
anyway it was it was essentially magneto
who had blanketed the earth in an EMP
and took down power to everything that
led to the x-men responding magneto
basically I'm sorry about Wolverine
jumped in and had the adamantium
stripped off of his body and then he
went forward his feral Wolverine where
we learned his calls were bone for the
first time this is very reminiscent of
that this is very real very much go back
to that in the sense that Wolverine
jumps in and tries to kill Magneto the
problem with this is that remember this
is Magneto this is one of the coolest
things about this story in any given
circumstance it probably would have
been magneto likes you know ripping the
adamantium out of his body it would have
been very easy to do that uh or taking
like some pipe somewhere and wrapping it
around Wolverine is throwing him out of
the out of the Citadel or whatever the
case may be instead what he does here is
he actually seizes control of Ironman
and Cyclops and is one of the coolest
things because you're talking about men
who are basically using metal and so
what uh what what magneto does is he
forces the visor of Cyclops open and
then he forces Ironman to shoot his
repulsor blasts and by being hit with
both forms of energy at the same time it
literally overwhelms Wolverine to the
point that he actually just be you know
is it's totally incinerated now again
this is one thing to bear in mind when
it comes to Wolverines healing factor
it's very very very very very
inconsistent in Marvel Comics Wolverines
one of those characters were how fast he
can heal and what he can heal from is
relative to the story that's being told
for example if you go and you read Chris
Claremont Days of Future past Ramon
Canty x-men 141 and 142 then like
Wolverine was killed when he was
incinerated by a sentinel and all that
was left was adamantium skeleton and
that was the end of him but if you go
back and you read like Civil War you're
right it's really the Wolverines hi in
for Civil War when he's tracking down
nitro and nitro explodes on Wolverine
and like burns him all the way down to
his adamantium his adamantium skeleton
Wolverine heals from it so is his his
healing factor is very very inconsistent
but one thing to also keep in mind is in
the Ultimate Universe Wolverines not
nearly as powerful or as capable as his
main Marvel counterpart meaning
adamantium is not as durable in the in
the Ultimate Universe as it is in the
main Marvel Universe and Wolverines
healing factor is a lot more toned down
the fact remains here that you know when
when you have the x-men trying to take
out like Iron Man and Cyclops really
subdue them more than outright destroy
them in his last few moments Wolverine
manages to like impale impale Magneto
which in turn leads to magneto stripping
all the adamantium off of Wolverines
body and again this is where things
begin to sort of differ a little bit the
adamantium being yanked off his body
like that it's enough to destroy
Wolverine in his entirety that's it
because all that's left is bone I mean
literally like he had a little bit of
flesh there but with the adamantium
being pulled off whatever flesh was
there comes with it so it's literally
just bone and sinew and that's the end
of him and things get pretty intense
here because at this moment what you do
is you switch over to the Incredible
Hulk and Colossus this is actually a
pretty smart move on behalf of Marvel in
terms of how they did this and the
reason why is because the Incredible
Hulk even in the Ultimate Universe is
still a pretty significant force to
reckon with and it's one of these things
were like if the Hulk had been there
alongside the other Avengers and even
the x-men to face off against Magneto
the fight would not have lasted very
long and he probably would have eaten it
but by taking him out of the equation
giving him a more reasonable task and
saying The Incredible Hulk and Colossus
his job is to destroy the engines
powering this Citadel that magneto is
using they still serve a purpose they're
still part of the story but it's not so
much that it's just like but why don't
they just fix everything why doesn't
hope just kill Magneto it's a pretty
effective thing but from there you
actually end up picking up with mystique
who attacks the two of them and then of
course the incredible turns around and
says it's time to eat mystique so of
course Sabretooth jumps in rescues
mystique and they essentially bail out
but again it's kind of cool here because
at this moment this is when you pick up
with Nick Fury and what happens is Nick
Fury sits down with magneto and says
you've been operating under false
pretenses this entire time you're
operating under the premise that mutants
are divine that they were basically
created by God and the mutants should
rise to power and take their rightful
place and if your responses you have no
idea what's actually going on so what
what Jean Grey does is she serves as a
kind of intermediary
she basically links the minds of Magneto
and Emma and Nick Fury and misses when
magneto learns and in fact this is
actually when we as the reader learned
that meant that mutants were basically
created the mutants were created when
the gene of Logan was discovered that if
it was activated he got a healing factor
if that chemical was synthesized and
spread throughout the world and that's
where mutants came from so again for
magneto is a crushing experience they're
really a crushing revelation because
what it means is he's been killing his
own people because again it's like the
Terrigen mists so it's like you know the
the genes are activated some have not
been activated some have and so he
destroyed potential mutants that exists
out there and so it's a pretty crushing
thing to have to come to grips with but
the fact that magneto recognizes this
means that there could have been a whole
new proliferation of mutants that he
actually could have taken things in a
different direction now in truth he
probably would have taken them in the
same violent direction it would have
been more of like an insurrection or
like an uprising of the mutant
population against humanity in its
entirety but he's basically forced to
accept the fact that he's been killing
his own people which is like the one
thing he never wanted to do and so in
light of this that the statements kind
of made look you know you'll never be
forgiven for what you've done
you know and initially like magneto is
almost in a state of like of like
insanity right because he's just kind of
like you know Charles will understand
Charles will forgive me Charles will
will you know he'll he'll understand
what I meant here and the response to
Cyclops is Charles Xavier is dead you
killed him no one's going to forgive you
the world will never forget and in this
moment he incinerates the face and it's
the entire head of magneto using his
optic beams so again it's
pretty wild here I mean it's a pretty
crazy ending to what I always thought
was a pretty cool story but at this
point what we do is we pick up outside
the US Capitol building and we basically
kind of switch over to the aftermath of
the events of ultimatum now for those of
you guys who are who really have been
reading like you know ultimate
spider-man or something like that and
you sort of crossed this moment where
mutants were suddenly hated this is the
reason why is because this event
basically initiated this massive
Cataclysm that almost destroyed the
whole of humanity and so because of this
humans have now switched to viewing
mutants as a credible threat and again
that's kind of the mo of mutants right
like mutants were always the group that
always the kind of like the outcast the
ones were never accepted by humanity by
whatever manner and whatever means
humanity rose to hate them and so it was
only a matter of time before you really
switched to like full-on hatred of
mutants but when you have a cyclops up
here talking to people it's kind of
interesting because what the
government's considering doing is
basically you know kind of implementing
the mutant Registration Act and that's
kind of the cool thing is because
remember Chris Claremont created the
mutant Registration Act way back in the
day way back in like the late 70s in the
early 80s and the idea of the mutant
Registration Act was the government
really all project wide awake responding
to the rise in the mutant population and
fine trying to find a way to control and
contain that was the whole you know the
whole idea behind it and so it's really
kind of seems to be this cycle repeating
itself here in the Ultimate Universe the
difference is that in this speech that
Cyclops makes to the - to humanity
really trying to appeal to humanity's
better side and say look do not turn us
over to the government do not allow the
government to pass a bill that will make
us register he's assassinated he's shot
in the head and it's just kind of like
wow so I mean it's it's literally the
worst case scenario for the mutant
population because everything is in
disarray everything is basically
crumbled it's all over the place and so
we kind of switch over for a second I'll
switch over to an aside or we end up
having dr. doom remember dr. doom is is
believed to have been the one that set
all this in motion right he was the guy
the the hidden hand behind it all and so
where he does have name of the
sub-mariner captive he's suddenly met by
the arrival of Ben Grimm but remember
Ben Grimm in the Ultimate Universe is
very very hardcore in comparison to his
main Marvel counterpart he pulls no
punches and so where he comes walking in
here his whole thing is like you have to
pay for the things you've done and where
Doom is sort of haughty he remember this
is not main Marvel Universe Doctor Doom
he's nowhere near as powerful and so
where he goes to challenge Ben Grimm
Finn Grimm crushes the skull he
literally kills him as though it's just
like it's it's like
like it's literally wrapping up all
loose ends and that's why I ultimatum
was a story where it was kind of
divisive because people looked at it and
they said but like they seem to be
killing people for no real reason and
then other people said but it's kind of
cool though because now you get a shift
in the status quo so again sort of
bouncing around fluctuating changing
different things like that and so what
we end up doing is picking up in the
aftermath kind of the epilogue for this
whole thing and we end up finding out
that the person who assassinated uh
Cyclops was actually Pietro Maximoff
himself that he uses SuperSpeed sent the
bullet flying at Cyclops and that's what
killed him but the idea here is that
Pietro and Wanda seem to have basically
survived and the idea was that they have
always been this vindictive they've
always been this dark and they were
trying to push magneto into the
direction of becoming as dark as them as
well the difference is that he never
really wanted to do it that way with
them they wanted to take a far more
dictatorial approach really more like
the the Mutant Liberation Front those
are guys who are familiar with the old
x-force comics by Rob Liefeld that's
really more the stance they were looking
to take something more heavy-handed
something more extreme and because they
consider magneto to be weaker the entire
idea of them of him being assassinated
the entire idea of Pietro Scott which of
them being taken out was all a ruse to
lead Magneto down this path so that
magneto would inevitably face off
against the Avengers and x-men would
either win or lose but regardless it
would set the stage for Pietro and Wanda
to rise to power and then initiate their
own campaign so it's it's it's patricide
basically it's it's pretty pretty
intense but again it goes forward with a
whole new status quo for like the for
the ultimate sand for cultivate x-men
and the whole nine yards but without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comets explain make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the robb
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
Oh